[Music]
5 16 on your friday morning what's cool
at school well hey how about some junior
news buddies in henderson
welcome to ibtv news my name is alex my
name is andrew some young men and women
at brown junior high school's
international baccalaureate academy are
opening the door to a potential career
choice either in front of a great baby
or behind the camera whether it's
telling their fellow students what's on
the lunch menu each day we'll be having
a spicy chicken sandwich with lettuce
and tomato pumping up sales of vegas
strong t-shirts scroll down and click
the link on our website or even an
occasional dad joke did you hear about
the rumor about butter no
well then i'm not gonna spread it
media production teacher mrs diaz says
her students take pride in creating
writing recording editing and producing
the daily video
[Applause]
[Music]
and some of those broadcasts have some
sports highlights for the junior high
school kids too and we do want to know
what's cool at school if you got
something let us know cool at school
under the community tab at 8newsnow.com
or just email cool at school at
8newsnow.com congratulations to mrs diaz
and those young men and women who are
absolutely learning how to do it not
just in front of the camera but behind
the camera as well a lot of work goes
into it yeah it never ceases to amaze me
how morning announcements which is what
they were doing basically has come so
far from when i was in high school and
it was just over the phone in the
principal's office exactly we're gonna
have meatloaf and pizza today
we're on the third bell schedule today
wow things have changed i wanted to be
on the morning now it's been so bad when
i was a kid oh yeah
no i wasn't cool enough oh time that's
why i'm on the morning show now it's my
please let him do that yeah take that
silverado high school did you do that
jerry brown uh i've been on a few
morning announcements not necessarily
for good things